c'est bien mclennan je prends la bagnole
c'est une course à faire minute papillon
ya des livraisons possibles
c'est pourquoi nous c'est hadash parce
qu'elle couscous est amer et pétri dans
toute la région
si tu veux la voiture tubes et la corse
non vous inquiétez pas je veux dire
qu'on va pas faire une réalisation télé
à la papa je dire on n'est pas au foot
tout se passe pas sur le terrain on est
à la pétanque là moi j'ai juste trois
clans par en pantacourt que j'ai des
boules de métal dont je suis obligé de
faire du spectacle à l'image donc à
partir de ce moment-là nous ce qu'on a
vu avec l'équipe télé c'est de faire des
plans daily kos voies de fait référence
fermeture du corry de destins machine
shop
c 'est joli dire que j'allais seule
matière ont pas peur à ses montres
voilà voilà voilà c'est mon dieu mais
voilà c'est ça donc là ça l'establisment
chimie à fond là est un fait peut-être
le bruit pour ces messieurs sera de
mieux que le chrono temps passé au final
il sera les équipes sont les faces rond
en attendant juste putten tu tires ou tu
pointes
ensuite les establishments une fois que
tout le monde s'est bien régalés on va
passer à autre chose et on ira un petit
peu plus peut-être chercher les détails
de matériaux des petits détails un petit
peu plus craquera où est ce que je veux
dire
du vivant que les gens se reconnaissent
dans l'assistance et puis alors à ce
moment-là qu'est ce que je comprends pas
à grands traits le fédéral est ce parce
que là on voit pas du tout
lalime a regardé voilà c'est ça pardon
voilà pardon voilà donc à ce moment là
la caméra va vraiment s'amuser aller
chercher les logos là on va dans le logo
poussez poussez trop
on le voit le logo le loup attendus dont
on rend grâce à votre contre chaque
point important ça servira d'intermèdes
entre chaque semaine et ça se fait très
longuement pour une chose je vais vous
dire une chose si tout est décidé ne me
dérangeait pas moi je suis j'ai six
rendez vous jo décalage horaire je vais
pas les soeurs mais voilà il ya de la
ferraille là j'aime pas ce qu on peut
vous aider vous cherchez ah oui je viens
pour la livraison la libre et ce
beaucoup ce couscous ça tombe bien je
suis ni pro vous pouvez juste déposé sa
liste face à lorient pas si simple oui
j'en ai marre des pizzas ça doit pas
ça doit pas quoi ça soit pas que vous
mangez des pizzas je comprends pas vous
êtes fine vous êtes et les violences ne
s'assoit pas que manger spieser j'ai
compris c'était un compliment
donc oui merci ça c'est la surmonter
c'est ma mère qui la préparent à paris
commence en fait comme toutes les mères
non la semoule
on ne comprend pas tous les deux